un covid 19 les premières semaines fut
très compliquées mais nous étions forts
et nous avons résisté il y a une semaine
l'Ukraine a fait l'objet
d'un autre État attaque d'un autre virus
il y a une semaine à 4h du matin la
Russie a attaqué notre pays indépendant
cette attaque cette agression
je vois maintenant que les chars les
requêtes sont
employés les premiers jours de cette
agression fut très compliqué et nous
avons résisté et nous allons résister à
l'avenir
que les forces russes ont dû changer
leur tactique
aussi toute une ligne de nos défenses
sont conservées
l'ennemi n'a pas réussi
peuvent plus faire contre nous qui Ève à
et de et debout et à résister bout si
isium personne toutes ces villes qui ont
fait l'objet de tirs aérien ne sont pas
ton nez cheerleague
résiste au dessin résiste ils essayent
de réunir notre odessin
monsieur ils y parviendront pas
la cathédrale de l'Assomption à Karkov
l'un des monuments historiques
ukrainien
et le symbole de défense pour tous les
Ukrainiens tous les Ukrainiens croyants
et non-croyants maintenant fais l'objet
de frappe ils n'ont peur de rien ils
n'ont peur même
de Dieu mais Dieu voit tout et régira
réagira de la façon forte vous trouverez
pas de refuge contre sa colère et la
cathédrale sera reconstruite
vous pensez que vous pouvez ruiner
toutes nos cathédrales mais vous allez
pas ruiner notre foi foi en Ukraine fois
nous allons reconstruire chaque ville
chaque site apprenez le mot la
réparation et la rétribution vous allez
réparer et vous allez nous dédommager
tout ce que vous faites nous
n'oublierons jamais rien tout comme le
dieu n'oubliera rien vous essayez
pour tous les
Ukrainiens là où il y a des
opérations militaires chaque citoyen
Ukrainiens qui ne peut plus travailler à
cause de la Fédération de Russie recevra
6500 grives nains
après
nous allons assurer le paiement de
toutes les retraites à partir du 1er
mars les retraites seront augmentées de
14% et tous les paysans des aides
sociales seront assurées l'Ukraine a
reçu des armes de la part de nos vrais
amis
c'est un munitions sont de plus en plus
importantes nous accueillons
plus de
16000 volontaires qui viennent à notre
secours et je suis persuadée que nous
allons
l'emporter nous sommes sur nos terres de
guerre mondiale
3 holocauses
toutes ces épreuves sont traversées par
notre peuple nous n'avons pas les
territoires du continent entier nous
n'avons pas d'armes nucléaires mais nous
avons notre peuple nos gens notaires et
ça cela c'est notre or nous nous battons
pour cet or pour la liberté pour notre
dignité c'est notre trésor le plus
important
la Russie
veut nous écraser effacer
nous sommes ici nous résistons nous
sommes debout
le monde entier nous aide et nous avons
traversé toutes les épreuves ici jamais
quelqu'un pense que les Ukrainiens
prennent peur et
dépose les armes
sachez que les Ukrainiens vont résister
il va chez toi rentre chez toi défendre
tes gens russophone non pas dans le
monde entier mais chez toi il y a 100 il
y en a 150 millions vivent l'Ukraine